foreign  [Music]  I know for a fact there would be no  circumstance that I would be comfortable  in Qatar attending the World Cup going  to matches I feel it's been tarnished  tarnished by the legacy of a country  that has so much work to do  we welcome everybody but also we expect  and we want people to respect our  culture  I have never been so afraid  Qatar does not have their resources  right now during the World Cup to go out  of their way hunting LGBT people  because the damage in the mind  but in Qatar people are not free to love  the person that they choose  I think he's made an absolutely  Monumental error of judgment in signing  up to be an ambassador for the World Cup  he's being sold for just what is just  another zero in his bank account which  would make no difference to him I think  it's a complete sellout